good morning believe nation today's
message is like your stuff over to you
Donald Glover
you really have to believe in yourself
and not and I like believe in yourself
way for like anything like you know what
you're getting out of it like you can't
change a lot of things around you and I
like a lot of people are gonna tell you
a lot of a lot of things you have to
have faith in yourself and I'm like you
know good friends around here so I would
just say like you know
be good to yourself like me like you
know believe in yourself do what you
want and be like cool if it be okay like
badly like yourself you know like it
like it you should be like nobody should
ever like you should never put out
something to be like this isn't a good
whatever like I like I think like I
think it's wack like that like
Macklemore is like of this powerful
shouldn't of one like Kendrick you
should have one I'm like that's why like
if you believe in that hobby should be
like I thought my homeless bed because
like that's it's me I think my albums
like the best I love my own I think it
felt like if I was a kid I'd be like
this albums the truth like why not like
your own stuff so yeah like your stuff
so it's like a call today with my
literary agent and we're talking about
the book that I'm writing and the book
has been cut in half we've cut up half
the content in the book we're going
through the editing process and she's
asking well do you still like the book
that we are about to release you still
you still like it there's like like it
this is I you know this isn't an amazing
book I love it I can't wait for it to
get out I wanted to start giving it the
people put it in their hand what what
kind of question what kind of question
is that
do authors not light the books that they
end up promoting and selling to me it's
mind boggling that that question even
exists like of course I like what if I
didn't like it I'd be fighting with you
right now over releasing it because I
don't want it to be put out like that
I think you've got my YouTube channel
and a lot of the stuff that I make this
series the expresso series a top-ten
series I mean for me I mean it for me
because I want to be surrounded by great
minds because I want daily content to
help stretch me and make me want to do
more and be better because it's easy to
wake up and be complacent do the same
thing you did yesterday it's easy to not
stretch yourself if you don't have
people around you saying hey I think you
could do more I think you know what
you've done is okay but you could be up
here you're playing way down here and a
lot of people don't have that enough and
their environment in their lives and I
don't have that enough in my environment
my life and in the videos the top 10
series in espresso series helps me I'm
glad that it helps you guys too I love
that it helps you I love sharing it with
you guys and getting your feedback on
who we should profile next I'm learning
from a lot of entrepreneurs I had never
even heard of before based off of your
feedback and suggestions but I would do
it even if if you guys hated it I would
still do it because it's for my growth
and development it's a selfish project
that I created that I'm sharing with you
guys and I'm so joyous that you guys are
enjoying it just like I am but I like it
you know people complained about a top
10 video an interesting video I don't I
love it
I review every video that goes out right
any top 10 video any expressive video
I'm watching it I'm looking at that clip
before it goes out maybe that's not the
best use of my time you know as a CEO
reviewing everything that goes out may
not be the best use of my time but it's
not just about creating the product this
I love the message and the content
itself and I wanted to have my stamp of
approval and I wanted to have an impact
on me because I feel like it was gonna
impact me that's the test right if it
impacts me this is an impact you guys
too and so the product or service that
you're creating you're putting out if
you're a musician you put it on a song
if you're an author in the book if you
are software developer you're creating
an app do you love it do you use it when
you listen to that song does it get you
excited when you use your app are you
looking at and using it every day would
you use it if it wasn't you know your
own app right like use your own stuff
make it for yourself like it be proud of
it enjoy it and then when somebody
questions it it's easy to send up to
them and say would be talking about this
is amazing stuff some new questions one
of my top 10 videos like you know you're
talking about this is an amazing video
I'm just feeling because I love it where
you weren't so proud of
and somebody hits you again soon yeah I
know you know I kind of mailed it in on
that one don't be that person don't mail
it in make it amazing like your stuff so
the question today today is what are you
most proud of that you've created in
your business single thing you've
created that you're most proud of really
curious to find out leave in the
comments below and also my goal is to
hit a million subscribers on this
channel so if you guys have any ideas of
suggestions or anything you can do to
help share it get the word out spread
this video a little bit I really really
really appreciate it thank you guys so
much for watching and have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso